how's it going bros my name is welcome
to i'm july i don't know what this is
you wrote suggested it I googled it
people said it's weird I'm I'm all for
weird let's do it we're talking to a
[ __ ] literally that's it right never
done that before
oh wait I have okay just use my
microphone [ __ ]
too many okay do you want to use this
app in chat [ __ ] no she can see me I can
give her a little treat don't care too
much for money because money can't buy
you luck well that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
look how happy she becomes [ __ ]
hypocrite and you'll understand this if
you not shake smile yawn show tongue no
no I bet she likes that one she realizes
I'm smiling to her unintentionally I'd
like to be your friend okay what's your
name for the pie I'm 18 how old are you
what is this [ __ ] what is that what is
that button dude why would I share this
[ __ ] but anyone no one should ever know
how I'm playing this piece of [ __ ] hey
don't pee on this up stuff okay you can
pee on this [ __ ] though my friends come
here to check try funny drinks Singur
just hang out what do you want to do ok
get drunk I guess you're ugly as [ __ ]
now there's a big happy grand well I
wanted my [ __ ] drink aren't you
smiling no let's talk about friends do
you have a best friend I'm sure you'll
find your best friend sooner or later in
the meantime how about you and I've met
my friends at school where did you meet
yours
what do you do with your friends I just
ask 2 questions before I [ __ ] answer
one I don't like I don't like dress-up
party would you tell your friends that
something look bad on them if it really
did yeah I would I'm honest I'll be nice
about it but I'm honest it pays to be
honest with your friends tell you if you
had food stuck between your teeth I hope
because I would say it
but sometimes it's better to stay
summoned especially if you can't change
anything want to hear how I screwed it
up once Oh
oMFG please dying to know oh I've always
wanted to chat with the ghost [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] did you call me um drugs it's
sitting in Paris and breathing can make
you high then I'm guilty I hate this
[ __ ] this is like worse than cleverbot
evie and everyone combined you look like
you need some tea and by D I mean
dinosaur dicks right
you better go cool off or don't sass me
because I will sack you back okay how
about we smile through her back don't
rock my [ __ ] [ __ ] stop it you'll
scare the birds away I love to make you
smile thank you
he's learning language is easy for you I
am blanching green dress me up my
closets full of nice stuff so [ __ ]
weird man alright tell me a joke
what is a cat's favorite song three
blind mice are you trying to be annoying
no why would you say that
why would what makes you say that how
many lives do you have
so maybe I'm near a 79 that's good to
know
that's useful information do you like
big butts I like it very much has a new
tattoo would you tell your friends right
away
search for pictures or ignore it I have
to where did it come from I like my nose
exactly where it is
hey babe pick her nice was that one of
your fall off a chair jokes no that was
a [ __ ] I hate you joke well if I could
touch her and she begins all like who
does this someone touches me I'm like if
you touch her butt sorry I didn't do
anything they don't do anything I can't
resist talking how do you keep up with
celebrity gossip what are your sources
can you tell
can't everyone you're right
can't believe I being so blind everyone
can teleport oh my god dismay so this is
a really really really weird [ __ ] act
like I can't wrap my head around it but
it's interesting I would say at least
they're like you know watching bras as
always I really do appreciate it very
much
but anyway hit subscribe convert today
I'll see you Bruce in the next 1000
births love you
[Music]
it's really good when you did that